[Música]
la abstención fue la gran protagonista
de las elecciones parlamentarias
anticipadas que se celebraron este fin
de semana en irak se espera que la elite
gobernante chiíta dominada por
islamistas gane la mayoría de votos
volvió la energía a líbano el ejército
aceptó darle seis mil quilos litros de
diésel a las dos centrales eléctricas
más grandes del país éstas produjeron un
apagón generalizado por la escasez de
combustible en sus plantas hoy se
celebra el día mundial de la salud
mental es una fecha promovida para crear
conciencia y movilizar esfuerzos en
apoyo de una mente saludable tendremos
invitada especial de la organización
panamericana de la salud
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 yo soy merece a la
calle y acompáñenme a seguir lo más
importante comencemos en irak donde ya
cerraron las urnas de las elecciones
parlamentarias anticipadas se espera que
los resultados se conozcan en dos días y
así definir los 329 escaños luego
vendrán las negociaciones para elegir un
primer ministro encargado de formar un
nuevo gobierno aunque miles de iraquíes
quieren un cambio pocos creen que los
candidatos independientes derrotan a los
políticos tradicionales a pesar de esto
la comisión electoral afirma que no hay
manera de sabotear el conteo de los
votos
este proceso electoral no puede ser
saboteado porque fue estudiado y se le
hizo un seguimiento
a nadie tiene que preocuparse por eso el
informe se imprime mediante una máquina
de resultados rápidos este informe se
presentará a los observadores y a los
organismos y el conteo a mano se
realizará frente a los observadores
así los resultados estén protegidos
muchos en irak consideran que estas
elecciones no son creíbles los
resultados se vieron en las urnas donde
hubo una gran abstención antes hablamos
con nuestra corresponsal en iran
catalina gómez ángel que nos explicó a
qué se debe la falta de participación
electoral
se prevé que sea incluso más alta a la
que ya fue en el 2018 cuando la
participación fue del
45% para entender bien estos porcentajes
de participación hay que ver que hoy son
las elecciones abiertas a la mayoría de
la población al 25 millones de iraquíes
que están habilitados para votar pero
dos días atrás fueron elecciones para
los militares para los desplazados y
para muchísimos funcionarios y en ese
escenario ya la participación sube por
encima del 70% así que tendremos una
participación más o menos similar a la
el 2018 que fue 45 por ciento lo que es
realmente un fracaso para las
instituciones políticas iraquíes que
habían respondido a ese llamado de esa
población en el 2019 de adelantar estas
elecciones y además de reformar esa ley
electoral trayendo por ejemplo creando
nuevos distritos electorales que
permitieran que esos candidatos no
llegaran a hacer candidatos por los
partidos políticos y no de manera
independiente con una intención de que
la gente participara muchísimo más y
sintiera mayor compromiso con estos
candidatos pero no y especialmente en la
población joven que es la que no ha
votado porque ve que no hay respuesta
hacia ellos no confían en la clase
política en la corrupción en la falta de
trabajo no hay servicios públicos y la
pobreza se ha hecho mayor como
consecuencia también de la pandemia así
que vamos a esperar como ya se prevé una
participación muy baja y vamos a ver
cuál va a ser la respuesta de los
políticos iraquíes
en otras noticias ya terminaron las
conversaciones entre eeuu y el grupo
talibán los diálogos que se realizaron
en qatar fueron los primeros que tuvo la
casa blanca con los extremistas
islámicos desde que estos tomando el
poder de afganistán ahora los talibanes
comenzarán una reunión con
representantes de la unión europea
también en la ciudad de doha occidente
está en una encrucijada pues intenta
dialogar con el talibán sin legitimar lo
todo mientras garantiza que la ayuda
humanitaria continúe
y el líbano se restableció la energía
después de un día de un apagón total por
la escasez de combustible en las dos
centrales eléctricas más grandes del
país la red energética volvió a
funcionar luego de que el ejército
libanés acordará darle seis mil quilos
litros de diesel a las dos compañías
fuera de la oscuridad total pero no
fuera del túnel un día después de
haberse paralizado las dos principales
centrales eléctricas del líbano
volvieron a funcionar luego de que el
ejército suministrar a un total de 6000
kilos litros de gasóleo el ministerio de
energía también ha recibido la
aprobación del banco central para pedir
un préstamo de 100 millones de dólares
para importar combustible para la
generación de electricidad pero las
empresas están al borde del colapso en
medio de la subida a los precios y el
empeoramiento de la crisis financiera
antes había electricidad durante dos
horas una de día y dos de noche ahora no
hay nada estamos sobreviviendo estamos
gastando de nuestros ahorros y de
nuestras propias reservas pero después
de un tiempo cuando nuestros ahorros se
acaben no podremos seguir
el apagón total del sábado fue el
segundo que afectó a líbano este mes con
la moneda nacional en caída libre los
envíos de combustible del extranjero se
han agotado los que pueden permitírselo
han recurrido a generadores privados
pero combustible para alimentarlos
también se ha vuelto difícil de
conseguir los precios de la electricidad
de las empresas privadas se dispararon
la energía generada por empresa cuesta
nada menos que 15 millones de libras
libanesas cómo podemos sobrevivir el
sector de la energía ha sido una enorme
fuga para las arcas del estado durante
décadas con la compañía nacional de
servicios públicos teniendo pérdidas
anuales de hasta 1500 millones de
dólares la reforma del sector ha sido
una exigencia clave de prestamistas
globales como el banco mundial y el
fondo monetario internacional
cada 10 de octubre se celebra el día
mundial de la salud mental recientemente
la universidad de queensland en
australia publicó el primer estudio
global sobre las consecuencias de la
pandemia en esta clase de salud y reveló
que el kobe 19 produjo 28 por ciento más
de casos de depresión y 26% más de
trastornos de ansiedad respecto a las
cifras habituales la organización
panamericana de la salud ya había
alertado que américa atravesaba una
crisis de salud mental por la pandemia
para hablar del tema está con nosotros
luz maría salazar consultora de salud
mental de la opc para colombia doctora
salazar bienvenida y cuéntenos cómo está
la salud mental en américa
si en este momento no la estamos
escuchando estamos teniendo problemas de
audio pero va perfecta ahora si la
escuchamos cuéntenos gracias la cob y 19
ha tenido un efecto devastador en la
salud mental de las personas en las
américas lo que afecta sobre todo a la
salud del bienestar y por supuesto la
estabilidad económica de toda la región
de las américas el estrés el miedo y el
trauma relacionado con la pandemia ha
creado una crisis de salud mental en
toda la región a lo largo de la pandemia
el estrés y el miedo han invadido
nuestra vida cotidiana lo que ha
provocado un aumento de problemas de
salud mental
relacionados con ansiedad y depresión la
amenaza en general del cobat ha obligado
a las personas como todos lo sabemos hay
las a instalarnos de nuestros amigos de
nuestros familiares y por supuesto un
porcentaje muy alto de la población ha
perdido su trabajo y luchan por mantener
a sus familias
bueno usted nos dice que el estrés y el
miedo vienen a lo largo del tiempo y no
solo en la pandemia pero a pesar de esto
según la misma o ps el gasto público
promedio en salud mental en américa es
del 2% esto es 0 8% menos que la media
mundial cuáles son las consecuencias de
esto
esto tiene unos efectos muy importantes
en la medida en que no hay recursos
suficientes pues las personas no tienen
el acceso suficiente para recibir
tratamiento si tienen problemas
asociados con trastornos en salud mental
en tiempos de pandemia igualmente los
servicios de salud sean
acortado y la gente no ha tenido la
posibilidad de acceder a los servicios
es muy importante ver la posibilidad de
que los gobiernos incrementen mucho más
el gasto público en los servicios de
salud mental y hablando precisamente del
papel de los gobiernos la organización
panamericana de la salud ha dicho que
chile costa rica y trinidad y tobago son
modelos a seguir en lo que respecta a la
atención psicosocial como son esos
planes y por qué son tan característicos
bueno supongo que están haciendo un
trabajo muy importante para que las
poblaciones vulnerables tengan un mayor
acceso a servicios de salud en este
sentido han fortalecido entonces la
salud mental comunitaria y han hecho que
la salud mental no solamente sea una
responsabilidad de salud sino que
también sectores como educación
protección sectores como el trabajo
tengan en cuenta la salud mental de toda
la población el tema de salud mental no
es responsabilidad solamente de salud
sino debe ser un tema transversal y e
intersectorial para realmente disminuir
las brechas de acceso a la salud de toda
la población
doctora salazar muchas gracias por su
información y esperemos que la salud
mental trascienda como usted lo dice los
servicios más allá de la salud nosotros
cambiamos de tema y hablamos del
presidente de la república checa- milos
semana quien fue hospitalizado de
emergencia y está en cuidados intensivos
su doctor personal explicó que el
mandatario fue remitido por una
enfermedad crónica y agregó que no
pueden dar mayores detalles pues no en
la aprobación presidencial para revelar
el diagnóstico la hospitalización de
semana coincide con las negociaciones
que lidera el mandatario para formar un
nuevo gobierno tras las elecciones
parlamentarias del sábado en las que los
comunistas perdieron
[Música]
y en italia hubo protestas contra el
llamado pase verde que prueba que una
persona está vacunada contra el cob y 19
o que ha padecido el virus este país
podría ser el primero en europa en
exigir el pase sanitario para ejercer el
derecho al trabajo mientras los anti
vacunas luchan en contra de esto en
muchos países en desarrollo hay un
déficit de dosis contra el coronavirus
juan pabló lucumí no es amplia
aunque avanza la vacunación mundial las
manifestaciones en contra de los
pasaportes sanitarios no dan tregua
miles de personas han protestado en
contra de su implementación en francia
alemania reino unido chipre y las más
recientes en italia aunque en marzo fue
concebido para facilitar los viajes
entre los estados de la unión europea
ahora en algunos países se ha presentado
como un documento obligatorio para
trabajar e ingresar a algunos
establecimientos
en italia se extenderá a todos sus
trabajadores tanto en el ámbito público
como privado con posibilidad de una
suspensión salarial para quienes se
nieguen a aportar este certificado las
multas están entre 600 a 1000 euros de
cumplirse italia se convertiría en el
primer país europeo en hacer obligatorio
el pase verde de kobe 19 para ejercer
actividades económicas el 15 de octubre
habrá finalmente una revolución en
italia no iremos a trabajar
porque tengo pues
el gobierno está obligando a sus
ciudadanos a vacunarse para conseguir
este pasaporte que les permite trabajar
para mí esto es un chantaje criminal y
cobarde por parte de nuestras más altas
instituciones
el certificado digital o en papel de
muestra la aplicación de al menos una
dosis de la vacuna que ha dado negativo
o se ha recuperado recientemente del
virus según cifras de la organización
nuestro mundo en datos el 46 5% de la
población mundial ha recibido al menos
una dosis contra el cob y 19 una
enfermedad que ha cobrado la vida de más
de 4.600.000 personas en todo el mundo
sigamos hablando de la pandemia pero
ahora en américa latina venezuela
recibió casi 26 millones de dosis contra
el cob y 19 la adquisición se hizo a
través del mecanismo kóvacs que
administra la organización mundial de la
salud también por kóvacs ya habían
llegado en lotes de sputnik y si novak
además de los contratos con la china
sino farm el ministro de salud
venezolano carlos alvarado afirmó que
las nuevas dos dosis impulsarán las
metas de vacunación
buenas noticias para venezuela está
llegando un nuevo cargamento de vacuna
para el cumplimiento de la meta que el
presidente nicolás maduro no ha exigido
del 70 por ciento de la población 2
millones 594 mil dosis de vacuna estas
vienen por el mecanismo cobats el
mecanismo al cual optó venezuela como
muchos países del mundo para adquirir un
número mayor de vacunas a través de esta
organización cambiemos de tema y
hablemos de taiwán y china porque siguen
las mayores tensiones que han tenido en
años luego de que el presidente chino xi
jinping dijo que tenía intenciones de
reunificar la isla con el resto del
gigante asiático la presidenta taiwanesa
enfatizó que la defensa nacional es la
vía para solucionar
xi jinping recibió respuesta a menos de
24 horas después de anunciar sus
intenciones de reunificación taiwán se
niega a ceder ante la presión china y le
ha apostado todo a la defensa nacional
no actuaremos apresuradamente pero no
debe haber ninguna ilusión de que el
pueblo taiwanés cederá ante la presión
continuaremos reforzando nuestra defensa
nacional y demostraremos nuestra
determinación de defendernos para
asegurar que nadie pueda forzar a taiwán
a seguir en el camino que china ha
dispuesto para nosotros la escalada
militar es la mayor de los últimos años
los sobrevuelos de aviones de beijing
sobre la isla de formosa fueron el
detonante pero la reivindicación de
china continental sobre taiwán es una
cuestión que viene de lejos
formosa fue el último refugio del
derrotado de ejército nacionalista
durante la guerra civil china y quedó
fuera del poder del partido comunista
desde entonces se autoproclama como un
estado independiente
la reunificación completa de nuestro
país debe realizarse y puede realizarse
la unificación es la esperanza de todo
el pueblo chino con inglés y va
si china puede unificar todos los chinos
disfrutarán de una vida feliz si china
no pueda unificarse todos sufrirán
piensan
la cuestión taiwanesa amenaza la
estabilidad de la región mientras taiwán
es un firme aliado de japón y eeuu china
considera que es un asunto interno sobre
una provincia rebelde que debe resolver
sigan conectados con la señal 24 horas
de france 24
[Música]